if you imagine quite far back you start
off MIDI Falls was one of the ways of
transmitting music initially over the
Internet then you added things called
mod files these were MIDI files with a
very small amount of audio normally
8-bit audio added to it
you're talking about 1980s video games
of the territory so was slightly better
sounding the MIDI was but considerably
worse than audio was and then a
compression technique starts to come in
with sort of a ten to one twenty to one
compression rates and you could get a
mono audio track down to something you
could easily download off the internet
so we're talking about a digital audio
fascinating topic I think you've done a
piece on it before just to recap taking
in a analog audio stream and then
sampling it both that way over time and
in that way over amplitude slightly rest
relevant today but obviously when the
internet first got it going you didn't
have much speed so he wanted to have
these files very much reduced you know
so take an audio file that was quite
massive squeezed it down so you can pull
over a small connection that led onto
the field of audio compression being
studied
[Music]
one of the studies was our understanding
of how we hear so clearly we don't want
to encode information it is irrelevant
to the way we hear requires us to
understand the problem here so let's
have a look at that so if you imagine in
your ear itself
this one will be pretty apt you've got a
bunch of little bones and then you've
got what's called a basilar membrane so
a piece of skin it's rolled up very much
like that and then alongside of it
you've got these little hairs
they're called cilia and what happens is
all the sound comes in different bits if
you imagine this basilar membrane
unrolled provide rate at different
points if it's a low frequency it
vibrates at one end if it's a high
frequency it vibrates to the other that
with the little nerves hairs underneath
then male or never firing up the brain
which enables you to perceive pitch
another higher level sort of concepts of
sound because of that rather limited
nature of hearing what happens is if
Iselle if there's a loud sound in a
certain area because the physical
membrane this vibrates but makes us
desensitized to other frequencies around
it yeah and that that's the basis by
which we get to do some aspects of
compression that particular bit is
called the cyclic ooo stick effects
which is how we perceive sound if we
like the legs I was kind of like you
lower sound and there you can kind of
hide the different frequencies and the
land sounds obscure the left lab sound
around a certain frequency because of
that physical membrane representation of
the frequencies and then there's been
huge amounts of studies to understand
how much it affects it to what degree
what you do is then you take your
digital audio and you can imagine doing
this yourself if you were and if you
have a done an audio multitrack system
you know sort of all of them they're
there Cubase whatever Pro Tools take
your audio track which would be a
constant audio stream you can imagine
filtering out into all its frequency
bands let's say from
20 Hertz 200 Hertz 100 Hertz to 500
Hertz and so on and so on and then you
can imagine sampling them at different
rates so this one might be 8-bit this
one might be 16-bit this one might be
24-bit and you know by sampling things
at different rate you effectively add a
bit of noise to it but you reduce the
overall amount of bits you need to
represent it so you lower the quality
but obviously your zero in the file size
yes but you're lowering the quality in
such a way that because of the other
sounds are going on you you can't
perceive it and if you plotted that out
this would be called a size of acoustic
mask and that means you can reduce the
amount of bits you need to describe
something but you can make very small
perceptual differences to the overall
sound and that that's one of the core
tenants so it's sort of using the the
rather oddities of the way our hearing
system has evolved which is you know far
from perfect obviously to take advantage
of that and then reduce the amount of
data and then you can do your normal
sort of compression tricks which work
for any type of data stream like I keep
seeing this string of digits come up so
I'm going to put those up in a lookup
table and encode it more efficiently
than just encoding those bits each time
no different than say Morse code does by
saying we use certain letters more than
you do others so I'm going to attribute
a short key length to those and there's
actually a whole technique around that
they called Huffman trees for anybody
who wants to look than that fascinating
things so you get you know all of the
other aspects information coding come
into play but that sort of excited COO
stick bit is the bit that's very audio
centric so it's a bit that has quite a
lot of relevancy so then there's not
other tricks like if you've got stereo
channels for comparing them in some way
or and taking information out that way
but there are some sort of basic tenants
of compression now that absolutely then
opened up the internet music since
people are still working the same way
now if you somebody you know listen to
Spotify and streaming audio is it there
well there any other tricks I use
whether dead lots of more trips I was
for me sort of compare this to any sort
of innovation so so there's a slightly
obscure but if you take the some like
steam engine revolution there was major
innovations and then people filled in
all the gaps in steam engine it with the
notion that there was a steam engine you
drive a piston off and then you can pump
water out of mine and then people put
wheels on it Internet your train and all
the other sorts of things but the the
fundamentals of it stay the same the the
people have then done significant
innovations inside of that but the
notion there is an understanding of how
you hear that clearly gets better over
time so that bits improved then there's
a notion of all of the encoding tricks
you can go do on information sources so
this is like encoding it as better
Huffman trees or whatever the modern
equivalents thereof so you get those
pieces but I think the fundamental
tenants that stayed the same just
evening and of the overall increases
have got better interesting also
obviously bandwidth constraint to come
down so the pressure has come off it a
little bit as well in terms of an
overall need when you come to this node
and you say I'm now going to descend to
the left again the rule is you add a
zero of what you've already got see when
it is zero zero how about this state you
come down on a zero but then you go to
the right every time you go to the right